Languages change over time,
but how fast,
let's say you fall into a coma, hearing
your language spoken all around you,
you snap awake in the same place,
but at a different time.
There's still speaking your language,
but you can't understand a word.
How long were you out?
How long can a language last
before it becomes unrecognizable?
Last time we met in eccentric
Australian tongue called Jubal,
a language where nouns
can be edible or harmful,
where you have to talk completely
differently around your inlaws and we're
speaking vaguely is considered a serious
flaw and they don't even have a word
for language.
At least it used to be that way because
when linguists came back to visit the
jitter ball non decades later,
they're language had changed.
Then we heard from Swatis
who argued that actually no,
all languages change at the same pace.
Replacing core vocabulary to constant
rate keeping over 80% of their most basic
words.
After a thousand years swat ish then used
his vocabulary lists and calculations
to draw a line marking how long we'd
expect to wait before dialects of a single
language evolve into separate tongues.
A line in the sand,
the elusive moment of change itself,
spot any problems with this idea
these researchers shore did.
They grabbed their Swatis lists and
pointed them at two sibling languages,
Norwegian and Icelandic.
The basic question they wanted
Swatis to answer was this,
how many years had passed between old
Norse and Norwegian and how many between
old Norse and I [inaudible] looking
at wordless for replacement,
plugging that stable rate assumption,
it looks like Norwegian
diverged a thousand years ago.
Not a bad estimate actually.
Well,
modern Icelandic is 200
something years old.
In other words, no one should be speaking
Icelandic right now. Call Up Iceland.
Your language is a mistake.
The numbers don't lie
today thinks to debunkings like this
and the fact that Icelandic exists
historical linguists except that the
rate of language change varies and for
various reasons.
According to this paper,
one factor could be population size.
In a computer simulation,
smaller populations borrowed and replaced
words faster than bigger communities.
The author of that Dribble Grammar
Dixon himself proposed another factor.
He called swatting as idea that Kimra
of glottal chronology and argued instead
that languages have long,
stable periods but then change in
punctuated bursts during moments of social
upheaval. So is that why Gerbil
changed so much? So fast,
a small population and a
quick punctuation? Well,
a careful look at the switch from
traditional durable too young,
durable suggests another variable.
The biggest reason why the language
changed much in just decades.
Language death.
A few decades before Dixon's grammar,
about 30 [inaudible] still lived around
the upper Tully river hanging onto the
old ways. But these days it seems
like nobody is learning durable,
threatening,
even young dribble with extinction.
It's not just assimilating to Australian
English or turning into a bare bones
pidgin or creel. This researcher
tells us it's not that simple.
Behind the steep change from
traditional journal too young,
durable was this smooth,
oldest to youngest.
Dropoff durable has been dying
its own death and language.
Death is its own variable
with all these complexities.
How long do we have to be out before
we wake up to a brand new language?
It depends.
Some tongue seem to keep their
shape over a thousand years.
Others do indeed changed
quickly within centuries,
but take another look at that question
we started with how long can a language
last before it becomes unrecognizable,
not unintelligible to earlier speakers,
utterly unrecognizable.
See, even if a time traveling Jubal
speaker couldn't understand the language,
they might still be able
to pick out familiar words.
How do we know this will happen?
Because it has happened.
This isn't the first time
[inaudible] has evolved.
We got a glimpse of its past changes in
part one when we met a relative of Juba
where the word for dog,
his dog,
that word took linguistic know how to
prove it was actually related to durable,
not English,
but other patterns among Australia's
languages are easier to recognize.
Whatever you think about Swatis lists,
here's a fun use for them.
Compare basic vocabulary from a bunch
of Australian languages and look for
cognates. Comparing cognates
and sound changes in grammar.
Linguists focusing on
Australia's languages looked
far back beyond dribble to
recover its entire family,
the Pama Newman languages.
There is dissent. Dixon in particular
came to reject this grouping,
but the consensus is that Paul Newman
constitutes the largest family on the
continent by far using
various lines of evidence.
Pama Newman is held to be
around 4,000 to 5,000 years old,
which is intriguing because look what
happens when we estimate the ages of other
language families.
We get similar time depths.
The one aberration here seems to be Prodo
Aphrodisiac of story for another time.
Some historical linguists worn that.
They don't do dates,
but some that do see a limit here.
Comparing languages can only take us
several thousand years into the past.
Of course,
in my tower of Babel first language video,
we did meet some mavericks
who dare to go even further,
so how long should we keep
that hypothetical linguistics
patient under to make
sure they wake up to a change to language?
Well,
within hundreds of years
we could expect degraded
with hand waving on dates and exactly
how understandable it will be,
but within many thousands of years,
even distant traces of the
language may have dissolved.
They'll keep your apologies handy
in case this answers too vague.
For the general bond
stick around at subscribed for language.